hey it's evan and today i'm going to be
showing you how to set your home page to
a file in your dropbox this comes from a
question from one of my twitter
followers elizabeth who wrote in the say
i'm watching your last pass tutorial how
do i get the home page on chrome with my
frequent accounts from dropbox me likey
and she's using chrome so
i'll show you why this is important so
if i load a new tab and i click home
this is what loads up and this for me is
my dashboard this is where i run my
business from it has everything personal
suppliers business daily everything that
i use on an ongoing basis i have on here
and as you can see up here in the url
it's a local file this is a dropbox file
that i put in the great reason i have it
on dropbox is because if i'm at home if
i'm at the office if i'm on the go it's
my default home page for all of my
browsers so that i have easy access to
everything that i need in one place how
to set this you can see that it's a
local link you're going to do file
semicolon the triple slash c users
esconito is my username dropbox folder
and then wherever you put in it so in my
case i created a folder called home page
and i named this file home page 3
because i've had various versions of it
this is my most recent one to
update this
in your chrome since she is using chrome
right
you click up here you look at the triple
bars here click that go down to settings
and then here it says the home button
and you can click change this might be
google this might be you know whatever
you have already set change
and then put in this uh the url and
again it's file semicolon triple slash c
semicolon slash users your username
dropbox and then whatever folder you've
put it in so i made a folder in my
dropbox homepage and named it home page
three so you put it in there press ok
press home
and you're done
so hopefully that helped elizabeth if
you guys watched this video you liked it
give it a thumbs up let me know what you
think leave a comment underneath your
comments help me keep going with these
videos and if you have a question for me
about technology or about your business
let me know underneath in the comments
and i'll make a video to reply just like
i did for elizabeth thank you guys and
i'll see you soon